[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous racontent la vie des
acteurs économiques du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines aujourd'hui
nous sommes à coignières chez xd motion
et xd motion c'est ça
[Musique]
ce nouveau flot
vous l'avez compris cette société est
spécialisée dans la prise de vue vidéo
avec différentes technologies utilisées
cette entreprise internationale à
différents projets des événements
sportifs aux tournages de films en
passant par la publicité et son prochain
objectif ce sont les jeux olympiques de
paris en 2024
c'est au programme de ce 28e numéro du
sky échos la société axle distribuer du
matériel pour personnes en situation de
handicap elle fournit notamment les
entreprises elle prépare actuellement la
diffusion des jeux olympiques de paris
2024 l'entreprise x démotion test des
technologies de prise de vue innovante
enfin la reprise dans le secteur
aéronautique vu par un salarié de
l'usiné permaswage c'est aux
clayes-sous-bois on commence cette
émission avec la semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées elle
se déroule du 15 au 21 novembre
l'occasion pour nous de nous intéresser
à l'entreprise ac sol si tu attrapes
elle est spécialisée dans la
distribution de matériel pour des
personnes en situation de handicap elle
fournit notamment des entreprises qui
accueillent des collaborateurs
handicapés focus sur cette activité
[Musique]
l'activité bilby aujourd'hui c'est
pratiquement 40% de l'ensemble de notre
de notre chiffre d'affaires nous
proposons différents types de matériels
les rangs pour pouvoir effectivement
accéder des appareils qu'ils ont pour
moi pouvoir permettre de franchir des
escaliers dont il monte escalier lorsque
le bâtiment est dépourvu d'ascenseur cas
de panne d'ascenseur en cas d'
d'évacuation d'urgence d'un incendie
nous disposons également de chaises
l'évacuation qui vont permettre à des
collaborateurs à des collègues
d'évacuer par les escaliers de façon
extrêmement simple des collaborateurs
qui sont en situation de handicap
[Musique]
pour des structures plus petites
petit surtout pme et tpe j'irai c'est
plutôt la volonté des managers ou des
dirigeants qui vont faire que les choses
vont évoluer
[Musique]
avec nous le dirigeant et fondateur des
x démotion benoît d'antan bonjour
bonjour
alors xd moshen existe depuis combien de
temps là bas ça fait onze ans maintenant
que la société a été créée alors comment
ça s'est passé la création et puis
comment a évolué cette société cette
création s'est passé ici à coignières
donc dans ces mille mètres carrés que
nous avons commencé avec juste cinquante
ou soixante mètres carrés d'utilisation
et aujourd'hui on est complètement fou
l'on verra tout à l'heure comment on est
en train de s'agrandir
becqueter 11 ans d'expérience de
services donc beaucoup d'événements
coupe du monde jeux olympiques événement
exceptionnel concert stade de france
bercy beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui se
passaient y compris dans le département
donc on est assez heureux de pouvoir
continuer pendant cette période
difficile à travailler autant la reprise
a été bonne donc une formidable équipe
qui continue à rayonner dans le monde
est là le dernier plus gros projets dont
sur lequel les équipes ont travaillé
c'est l'exposition universelle de dubaï
très rapidement un un mot sur la manière
dont vous avez traversé la crise
sanitaire alors en fait la crise
sanitaire grâce à la robotisation et
tous les systèmes qui aujourd'hui se
passe en distance un tout le monde a dit
sensations que vous savez tout le monde
fait des conférences aujourd'hui tine
zoom et dans le fonctionnement à
distance nous c'est la même chose au
niveau broadcast de plus en plus
d'outils technologiques de ce mode là
sont utilisés et grâce à cela beaucoup
d'entreprises ont eu besoin de
communiquer avec cette robotisation à
distance et donc nous ont commandé du
matériel un mot sur justement
l'évolution technologique vous en parler
du nouveau matériel je suppose il y
trône il ya toutes les caméras qui aussi
qui évolue alors en fait la grosse
évolution aujourd'hui qu'il est en train
de se passer c'est la remote production
donc principalement aujourd'hui on
télécommande à distance les systèmes par
la fibre optique mais maintenant plus
récemment et grâce au consortium qui est
en train de se mettre en place avec le
vélodrome de saint quentin 5 g nokia et
tous les partenaires de france tv lab et
le vélodrome directement en fait on à
l'utilisation maintenant de la 5g pour
pouvoir piloter à distance nos systèmes
donc ça c'est la grosse évolution qui
est en préparation on reviendra dessus
pour les jo de paris 24 11 ans
maintenant les jeux olympiques de paris
2024 c'est une véritable opportunité
pour votre société c'est extraordinaire
mois depuis maintenant les jeux
d'albertville donc ça remonte quand même
en 92
les effectivement les jeux olympiques
d'athènes en 2004 aujourd'hui on les a
tous couverts on part on vient de finir
tokyo avec tous les drones qui ont été
qui ont été utilisés là bas sur place et
en chine on nous allons tourner tout les
sports extrêmes avec nos technologies
cablecom juste une précision la chine
c'est parce qu'il ya les jeux olympiques
d'hiver 2022 c'est ça exactement donc là
en fait on vient de terminer tokyo l'été
2021 et nous partons donc avec l'année
de décalage donc au vide sur 2022 en
chine et on préparera dans la foulée
paris 2024 en france avec quatre sites
olympiques comme vous savez sur le
département et donc on travaille
énormément en ce moment 1 que la
préparation de ces jeux nous avons lancé
du cio championnt ligue dont les tests
ont été faits au vélodrome en
avant-première donc c'était extrêmement
important de avec cette rencontre
guillaume cyr séraphine et bruce du
vélodrome pour lequel on a réalisé ces
essais etc je dirais les prémices de ce
qui va être utilisé par la suite sur
paris 2024 est-ce que vous pouvez nous
décrire justement les images qu'on voit
là de cette démonstration alors cette
démonstration a eu lieu courant novembre
donc juste avant de partir sur la
première événement la première session à
palma là ce que vous voyez c'est la
grande vitesse de déplacement du ce
qu'on appelle le xliv un des câbles
calmes sur lequel nous avons rajouté
l'arrêté augmente et donc je vous
expliquais les tendances du marché et de
son évolution donc la remote production
et la réalité augmentée donc tous les
graphismes virtuel qui vient d'être
ajouté que vous allez que vous vous
allez bientôt voir en live sur la
prochaine épreuve qui va avoir lieu en
lituanie et on espère très prochainement
l'année prochaine en 2022 au vélodrome
en ce moment même vous faites des essais
dans votre xd motion lab oui le design
lab le xd motion lab en fait les moteurs
de jeu reeves qui sont utilisés dans le
monde entier ont d lab qui permettent
aux je dirais à tous les ingénieurs de
pouvoir développer ces technologies donc
on a décidé d'ouvrir ce lab pour que je
dirais tous nos clients puissent venir
voir notre technologie vous pouvez
prendre un rendez-vous à avoir une
visualisation en direct en live de cette
technologie la grâce à cela ben c'est un
échange d'une communauté d'ingénieurs
qui permet de faire évoluer la
technologie et bien benoît d'antan on
voit tout de suite vous transférez dans
ce x10 motion lab en réalité augmentée
c'est parti là bas je me tais les portes
vous êtes maintenant chez xd motion lab
le principe en fait c'est d'utiliser
donc ce nouveau robot six axes qui est
équipé d'une caméra haute définition
cette caméra donc est relié sur le bras
en mouvement et permet en fait grâce à
ce fonds vert de pouvoir faire de la
production virtuelle
aujourd'hui nous utilisons donc des
jeunes jean 3d sur base des drills qui
s'appelle pic ce top avec nos amis et
collègues de postes le gie qui sont
vraiment les professionnels de cette
techno là
en deux mots toute la réalité augmentée
fonctionne grâce à ce type de
technologie aujourd'hui qui est de
remplacer le monde réel par le monde
virtuel et de mixer les deux
technologies donc ce bras est à la fois
très souple et silencieux il se déplace
donc dans l'est
trois dimensions et à la faculté de
pouvoir aussi gérer des points de vue
très spécifique en mouvement et très
précis et comme vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi la scène virtuelle est
totalement traquer et liés à ce type de
mouvements en trois dimensions
donc on a véritablement cette capacité
technologique de pouvoir travailler
aussi henri mode production c'est à dire
que le robot étant complètement
opérationnels en ip on peut
véritablement aujourd'hui le
télécommandée à distance à des milliers
de kilomètres grâce à la fibre ou même
grâce dans le dans le consortium
aujourd'hui de la 5g au vélodrome de
saint quentin avoir la capacité de
piloter ce robot en 5 j grâce à des
puces aujourd'hui qui sont opérationnels
et nos partenaires de nokia qui
travaille avec france tv là bas sur ce
type de techno donc aujourd'hui une
révolution est en marche
la robotique avec des caméras ptz et
pilotage par notre logiciel ayew bottes
permet d'aller jusqu'à des dizaines de
caméras pilotés à distance et donc
d'utiliser que ce soit en corporate pour
les entreprises en tv broadcast sur le
bord d'un terrain comme ceux sur ce que
l'on tourne aussi sur les six nations du
rugby du stade de france où les jeux
olympiques ce type de technologie c'est
un secteur frappé par la crise sanitaire
l'aéronautique avec parfois des
conséquences sociales c'est ce qu'a vécu
l'année dernière l'entreprise permaswage
qui a connu un conflit social résolu
grâce à un accord trouvé avec les
partenaires sociaux
depuis l'activité a repris c'est le cas
notamment pour stéphane pichot rookie et
collaborateurs au sein de l' usine
permaswage une rencontre dans cette
séquence ma vie de salarié
[Musique]
je m'appelle discours stéphane j'ai 52
ans je travaille à l'usiné permaswage
aux clayes-sous-bois je suis tourneur
sur commandes numériques opérateur
régleur depuis 18 ans
occupe actuellement la fonction de
opérateur régleur sur l'îlot au numéro 5
mon activité a consisté à faire à
fabriquer des pièces suivant un plan
rien et un programme j'alimente je
décharge et je contrôle les pièces à
100%
les pièces ce sont des raccords
hydrauliques
où passez du du kérosène de l'huile
suivant suivant où elle se se met sur un
appareil elles peuvent être droite elles
peuvent être coude et à 45 degrés elles
peuvent être coude et à 90 degrés il
peut y avoir deux branches trois
branches qu'on fait est essentiellement
airbus est la leur actuelle ce sont des
pièces en titane qui sont qu'ils sont
pour le fabricant d'assaut
[Musique]
ce qui est passionnant c'est que l'on
fait jamais la même chose moi j'aime
bien c'est on on parle on part d'un
matrix et donc à ma tristesse et une
pièce brut et on la finaliste à la fin
et on y met en images nous mène dans la
pièce parce que bon il faut qu'elle
sorte bonne et on doit faire très
attention à ça
c'était un coup assez dur parce que ça
c'est du jour au lendemain bah on nous a
dit vous restez chez vous maintenant que
ça va mieux que la reprise est là c'est
très bien
c'est vous les côtes en devenir quoi
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi une émission que vous
pouvez revoir en replay sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]